O5-9 was having a lazy morning. After all,
while being a member of the O5 Council is
a demanding job, it doesn’t mean that
you don’t occasionally have off-days.
His schedule was clear, so he decided to catch up
on some YouTube videos he’d been meaning to watch,
water his plants, and play some office golf to
ease off the boredom. That’s when he received
a strange message from O5-1 on the closed
O5 Council Communications Relay Network.
It read, “Nine, attached are files we
found last week within Site-01's Deepwell.
I wouldn't trouble you with this if not for
the fact that the events described herein
have never occurred. Their initial creation
date is approximately 50,000 years back.
Please familiarize yourself with
them as quickly as possible.”
And just like that, O5-9’s lazy day had been
torpedoed. He put away his golfing equipment,
and accessed the file: Strangely,
it read: ACCESSING FILE: SCP-6789,
ITERATION ONE, 30/08/1825. You can probably
see the inconsistency already: “50,000 years
ago” and “1825” don’t make for the most congruent
timeline. This would definitely warrant further
exploration, even if it meant eliminating
his chances of a fun office golf day…
The file described an anomalous presence
in a room beneath the Rollander General
Steel factory in Częstochowa, Poland,
where the speed of organic material growth is
absurdly fast, in a manner similar to the growth
stimulated by the neutralized anomaly SCP-407,
also known as The Song of Genesis. However,
the anomaly itself didn’t concern O5-9 nearly
as much as its location. Częstochowa, Poland.
Perhaps not the first place on anyone’s dream
vacation destination list, but one of the most
important anomalous locations in the world.
We’re going to need to take a minute
to explain a few key concepts to you.
Namely, the concept of Free Ports,
Esterberg, and Site-120. You see,
while it is the Foundation’s prerogative to secure
and contain anomalies where they might intersect
with humanity and thus threaten the upholding of
consensus reality, there are certain places where
doing so just isn’t practical or possible. They’re
big places, sometimes on our dimensional plane,
sometimes residing in others, with
large and largely anomalous populations.
To borrow an example from the Foundation files,
picture a New York City where everyone inside is
a mix of Fae, aliens, animal people,
magic practitioners, or the undead.
A full anomalous community, permanently situated
in a given location. It’s too separate and
secluded enough from humanity to necessitate
full containment, and if we’re being realistic,
the Foundation couldn’t contain them
without a great deal of hassle anyway.
A location like this is known as a
Nexus. However, particularly large
nexuses that also act as hubs of anomalous
trade and commerce are known as Free Ports.
Free Ports are a complicated
situation for the SCP Foundation,
in a bureaucratic sense. International and
interdimensional law forbid the Foundation
from intervening in the matters of
Free Ports without proper permission.
These places are highly autonomous zones, with
their own internal laws and law enforcement. Free
Ports often exist on separate planes of existence,
and can only be entered through anomalous means,
meaning accidental interactions with humans from
Free Ports are extremely unlikely. Therefore,
in these special autonomous zones,
the veil can be entirely lifted.
One such Free Port is the city of Esterberg -
designated SCP-5373 by the Foundation - which is
a particularly special case. It’s the largest
entirely anomalous city that is not under
Foundation control. It has a high Fae population,
hence its name, which means “City of the East” in
the Fae language. It’s an immensely powerful and
important place, where magic and reality-bending
are just parts of everyday life. And as you’ve
probably intuited at this point, being the smart,
good-looking, and charismatic fans of SCP
Explained, the Free Port of Esterberg is situated
in a pocket dimension directly parallel to
Częstochowa, Poland. This brings us to Site-120.
SCP Foundation Częstochowian Research and
Reliquary Dimensional Containment Facility,
abbreviated to Site-120, is a unique location,
as far as Foundation facilities go. For starters,
it’s built on an abandoned industrial facility
on top of a different anomalous nexus:
SCP-5292, also known as the Library of
Babel. This is a huge interdimensional library
complex heavily associated with the Fae,
containing a countless number of ancient volumes
written in languages unknown to humankind. This
feels like an apt metaphor for the primary
purpose of Site-120 and its staff: Bridging
the gap between the Foundation and anomalous
communities like the Free Port of Esterberg.
And it should come as a surprise to
nobody that this is one hell of a gap.
The population of Esterberg largely distrusts,
fears, or outright despises the SCP Foundation,
given that their typical attitude to anomalies
is less “brotherly love” and more “getting
black-bagged by a Mobile Task Force and
carried off to a paranormal black site.”
They have somewhat of a reputation for being
gung-ho brutes, or Jailors, as the Serpent’s Hand
likes to refer to them. That’s why Site-120 has a
very delicate diplomatic situation on its hands.
And to deal with this situation, they created a
specialized task force known as the Inter-Species
Communications Team, with 27 well-trained
researchers, negotiators, and diplomats,
headed by Dr. Anna Szulc. They’re doing
all they can to extend the anomalous olive
branch to the communities within Esterberg and
improve the Foundation’s standing among them.
So, needless to say, the situation over in
Częstochowa, Poland, is exceedingly complicated,
and as O5-9 read further through the
document on SCP-6789, he just hoped
that they weren’t all staring down the barrel
of a future diplomatic or containment snafu.
Though O5-9 had no idea just how crazy
everything was going to get with SCP-6789…
At first, the anomaly seemed pretty
straightforward. It was confined to an
unlit sub-basement boiler room in
the Rollander General Steel factory.
However, despite the lack of light or really
any of the conditions necessary for supporting
life that isn’t insects or fungus, a glorious,
flourishing microcosm has developed down there.
Flora and fauna abound and seem to be
developing safely in a complete ecosystem.
Workers and Foundation researchers,
upon entering this area,
reported hearing a low thrum similar in sound and
rhythm to a heartbeat all around them. Though this
sound hasn’t been recorded outside the claims of
those who supposedly experienced it first hand.
Workers of the steel mill reported feeling
a tremendous sense of calmness and wonder
while inside SCP-6789. They would walk into the
boiler room whenever they felt stressed between
shifts, and watch sprouts growing
up around their feet in real-time,
and small animals like rabbits and hares
hopping out of what seemed like nothingness.
It was a place of wonder. A
gift from Mother Nature herself:
An opportunity to feel the warmth and
the rhythm of her very beating heart.
However, this ran into problems when the plant
growth obstructed the operations of the steel
mill, shutting down its main boiler. This
led to the Rollander General Steel company
pressuring one Thomas Williams, head of the
technical repair team, to effectively destroy
SCP-6789 and install a new boiler where it had
once been. When he expressed reluctance to trample
on this hallowed ground, they threatened
his job and the livelihood of his family.
With great pain and reluctance, he followed
through with their destructive orders.
During a Foundation exit interview,
Williams tearfully recounted, “I—
I didn't want to. They said they'd come
after my staff, my family. Cut our wages, I…
I torched the room. Tore out the old machine and
put the new one in. My men hated me for it. Called
me a monster for what I made them do. The sounds
that place made whilst it burned… I don't know
what drove me to defile such a gift of nature.
Greed, or fear. Or both. You will let me know if
anything happens down there, won't you? I need to
know if it can regrow. It must be able to, right?”
And in a strange twist of fate, SCP-6789
did begin to come back. And even stranger,
it began to expand further, causing unchecked
growth in the rooms around the boiler room.
Studies at the time noted that the growth was
accelerating by a pace of 0.6 m every 24 hours.
But of course, this was only the beginning.
By the year 1947, the majority of the city
of Częstochowa, Poland, had been consumed by
an ever-evolving SCP-6789. Not only had the
growth rate been increasing exponentially,
but the actual anomalous effects of the 6789
field were becoming more varied and powerful.
Plants as large as twenty meters in height were
bursting out of the ground. Observers noticed
significant differences between the plants within
the 6789 area of effect and the ones outside,
suggesting the results of millions of years of
evolution being achieved in a mere handful of
decades. It didn’t take long for 70% of the city
to be consumed, leading to a mass evacuation.
From a distance, the energy field of
SCP-6789 is visible around the city,
appearing almost like a huge, translucent dome
capping it from overhead - though tests have
revealed that the other side of a massive energy
sphere stretches beneath the earth’s crust.
Being inside the energy field can be
dangerous for non-anomalous civilians,
as the plants have a strange memetic effect
of inducing unconsciousness in anyone with
a Cognitive Resistance Value (CRV) of less than
20. This pernicious effect has resulted in the
loss of almost 99% of the civilian population,
though we should specify, they are not dead.
On the contrary, the people knocked
unconscious within SCP-6789 enter a
state of stasis where their health gradually
improves without the need for nutrition.
A team from MTF Epsilon-3, also
known as the "Atypical Philosophers",
was sent into the belly of the beast on a recon
mission to re-establish contact with Site-120,
which was one of the first areas to be taken
over by the ever-expanding SCP-6789. The team
members marveled at the transformed world within
the energy sphere. It had been reclaimed entirely
by mother nature, transforming it into a world
that seemed at once alien and familiar. As they
progressed deeper within, they couldn’t help
but feel an odd sense of tiredness taking over.
Eventually, they reached and breached
Site-120. On the inside, the site’s staff
were cocooned in bizarre, translucent pods
that seemed to have a rejuvenating effect.
They also couldn’t help but notice the loud,
thrumming heartbeat that echoed throughout the
facility. However, before they could
successfully call in reinforcements,
the memetic effects of SCP-6789 took over. Each of
them collapsed to the ground, falling unconscious.
To get a better look at some of the
flora and fauna within SCP-6789,
a Foundation researcher kept a comprehensive
record of notes on some of the various
plants and animals of interest she
recorded within the affected area.
Upon seeing a flock of several thousand
flying birds, she noted, “If we can find
a way to study SCP-6789's methods, we may be
able to find a practical use for the anomaly.
I have not seen a flock this size since my
childhood, from before the War. It brought
back memories I thought I’d never feel again. I
will speak to my superiors for more resources.”
After seeing a group of Eurasian Brown
Bears hunting a herd of Thomson’s gazelle,
she noted, “This confirms SCP-6789 is
capable of producing species foreign
to Europe. It should be noted that this
creates the potential for catastrophe.
We can no longer comfortably predict
what might come out of there.”
After seeing some nesting, formerly
extinct flightless birds known as the
Great Auk nesting, she wrote down, “We spotted
the birds from the boat when Mgr. Białas,
our resident ornithologist, heard a
birdcall she did not immediately recognize.
We soon spotted the great auks on
the cliffs nursing their young.
This confirms SCP-6789 is capable of bringing
back extinct species, but to what extent? And
by what means? Could we somehow harness
this power to turn back our own aging?”
Upon seeing an incredible herd comprised of
thousands of specimens from an extinct bovine
species known as Aurochs, she noted, “Magnificent.
I had thought the large mammals of Europe were
all but extinct. Our expedition encountered the
herd moving north along the river towards Poznań,
but we managed to intercept them and keep
them within SCP-6789's exclusion zone.”
After seeing a series of genetically mutated
Kapok trees that grew so fast they destroyed
the surrounding Foundation research centers,
she noted, “In light of recent incidents,
further expeditions into SCP-6789 have
been indefinitely suspended. Sufficient
information has been gathered regarding
SCP-6789’s capabilities and practical use.
Continued research has been deemed
a waste of Foundation resources.
A controlled burn of the plant growth
has been authorized by the High Council.
Upon confirmation of the anomaly’s annihilation,
SCP-6789 will be reclassified as Neutralized.”
But of course, it was never
going to be that easy, was it?
By the year 1989, SCP-6789 had claimed the
entirety of Poland. Things had gotten so
severe that the Foundation needed to use a
custom-made antimeme, in addition to mass
applications of amnestics and efforts to scrub
all references to the country from recorded media,
to completely wipe any memory of Poland’s
existence from the global consciousness
while they tried to solve this SCP-6789 situation.
But the prospect of any such solution began to
seem more and more like using a bandaid to cure
a decapitation as things spiraled out of control.
At first, the Foundation could curtail the
growth of the 6789 area through controlled
burns with thaumatologically-enhanced fire. This,
however, did not impact the continued growth
for long. Researchers predicted that an IK-Class
"Collapse of Global Civilization" Scenario could
potentially occur in as little as seven months.
However, while these developments
were all a net-minus for humanity,
they created wonderful opportunities for a few
species that humanity had wronged in the past:
The Children of the Forest, a subset
of the Fae that was wiped out after the
battle at The Factory, and The Children of the
Night, better known as SCP-1000, or Bigfoot.
Surviving members of Inter-Species Communications
Team from Site-120 attempted to start a dialogue
with these cultures forming in the ever-growing
SCP-6789 area that was once Poland. However,
given the incredibly fractious history between
humanity and these two groups, they were not met
with a warm reception. Repeated attempts to enter
the domain of SCP-1000 and communicate with them
were met with the following series of aggressive
communique from the Children of the Night:
“do not attempt contact at the time;
no reason to trust
we will respond with force.”
“all entry into our reclaimed terrain
will be understood as a violation of this request;
stop all attempts.”
“we see your attempts
we will not warn again
Cease.”
“mother does not wish for us to meet with you;
we therefore listen
do as she says or meet the consequences.”
It’s probably clear by this point that
the SCP Foundation was barking up the
wrong genetically mutated Kapok tree. They had
burned their bridges with all these species with
their own selfish actions, and would never
again be seen as friends to them. However,
some answers were provided by a Child of the
Night that was at least willing to speak to
them in English - even though he resented
everything they stood for. He informed them
that they had invoked the very wrath of
mother nature with their terrible actions,
and now, they were taking revenge. In
his chilling closing statement, he said:
“Look what you did to us. Look what
you did to the Children of the Forest.
We forgave you. Your siblings gave up on
fighting back, but your mother's heart is
broken. She gave you life, and you showed her your
true colors the moment she left you off her leash.
She birthed you, yet you chose to betray
her in the most disgusting way possible.
Get out there and wait as mother nature
does her job at neutralizing your poison.
She didn't give up on you. No, not
yet. Unlike yourself, that is.”
And of course, it would only get worse from there.
By 2066, it was all over. The ever-expanding
SCP-6789 had consumed almost the entire planet,
leaving the surviving Foundation population
to seek what remained of refuge on a boat,
set permanently adrift. All they could do was
watch as Mother Nature claimed her vengeance
against the human race and took over the Earth,
while they planned desperately against her. The
beating heart of SCP-6789 developed roots that
reached way down into the depths of the earth,
giving it access to life everywhere.
Much like the SCP-1000 specimen had said,
it seems plausible that this entity
was the source of all life on earth.
Our one true mother.
Of North America, the Foundation wrote,
“Following SCP-6789's manifestation in the
North American continent, Yellowstone Base
has been lost, with all personnel having
been evacuated before the spread of SCP-6789
into the Duchy of Wyoming. SCP-2000 remains
accessible through direct portals, as SCP-6789
structures do not appear to have penetrated
the insides of the underground complex
housing it; it's unknown why this occurred,
considering SCP-6789's attraction to machinery.
Similar to other Foundation sites worldwide,
Yellowstone Base has lost its main purpose — the
Great Yellowstone Supervolcano, which was once
monitored and restrained has been noted to cease
volcanic activity. Most nearby areas previously
thought to be inhospitable have been healed and
are populated by wild flora and fauna alike.”
Of Libya, they wrote, “The main difference
between pre-SCP-6789 Libya and post was the total
destruction of more than 274 industrial complexes
which were once the country's pride. Of note is
the total decontamination of the connection
between the Libyan Ocean and the mainland;
this change has been so extreme that even the
Devil's Throat is now clear of all traces of oil
contamination. Similarly, the Great Libyan
Canal is once again accessible through the
European Straight despite once being blocked
by industrial waste for more than 27 years.”
Of Antarctica, they wrote, “Despite the extremely
harsh environment created by the Antarctic Empire,
SCP-6789 growths did not struggle
with adapting to the conditions;
in actuality, most floral megastructures spawned
around the country were noted to be the largest on
record. Growths were noted to be universally dense
regardless of human development, unlike previous
trends — the only exception to this rule was the
complete destruction of the country's floating
capital. It's theorized that this was caused
by the city's proximity to the Ozone Hole.”
Of Poland, where it all began, they wrote, “Being
the origin point for the entire anomaly, Poland's
entire area is dense with SCP-6789 flora. Despite
this, the most compact area is the core itself,
the Silesian Voivodeship. There, numerous
formations and structures which do not appear
to be present anywhere else in the world are
located — examples include trees larger than 100
meters in height or half-transparent biological
domes acting as insulative barriers for the most
polluted areas. All such places have been noted
to heal much more quickly, with instruments noting
that Poland's once poisonous groundwater is now at
an almost perfect level of quality. Fish and other
water life have since repopulated these waterways
as they did before the industrial revolution.”
Of the remote Tuvalu States, they wrote,
“The situation noted in the Tuvalu States
is certainly the most unusual — though
not because of what most would expect.
Throughout the entire country,
almost no plants exist.
Large tracts of land consistently possess
almost no growths whatsoever. The Tuvalu
States account for more than 75% of the planet's
surface that has yet to succumb to SCP-6789.
The only parts of the country that have
been effected are the highly populated
industrial complexes, though these account
for less than 0.00001% of the country's area.
Although an attempt was made at establishing a
Foundation Base within Tuvalu, all expeditions
were met with failure due to resistance from
SCP-6789 towards all construction efforts.
Further plans were stopped once Foundation Naval
Base-01 was designated as humanity's safe haven.”
As time went on, the dwindling O5 Council,
dropping off one by one, tried their best to
implement some method of fighting back. Some of
the many, many failed attempts included “Via the
usage of Foundation physicists, thaumaturgists,
and theologists, attempt to contact the deity
located within SCP-6789's core. Use Foundation
rituals to imprison, reason with, destroy,
or otherwise neutralize the entity” and “Via the
usage of a Foundation-developed anomalous disease
specific to SCP-6789's floral structures,
attempt to reclaim critical Foundation bases
and habitation centers. Resume previous
containment efforts once successful.”
All that seemed to be left was the nuclear
option. Attempt 67. The bottom of the file read:
“Via the usage of Project Lethe and
Kholoud-memetic triggers, revert humanity's state
of development to pre-industrial times through the
degradation of brain development. Rob humanity of
thousands of years of scientific, cultural, and
technological development. Await total destruction
of modern infrastructure by SCP-6789 and the
release of all individuals from SCP-6789's effect.
Apply Ennui Protocol following its success.”
O5-9’s eyes darted to the corner of the screen.
He had a new message from O5-1, reading: “Today,
RAISA detected the following draft for a file
being uploaded for approval to SCiPNet. I'll
just let you draw the conclusions yourself.”
O5-9 opened the file draft. And it looked just
like the first file, all over again. In the end,
the Foundation had succeeded, but on
some level, it had been a hollow success.
Is all they’d done to propagate the loop for
another generation, just waiting to happen again?
Would the heart of Mother Nature
someday beat again in pain and
rage from the betrayal of her children? Would
SCP-6789 ever truly be defeated or contained?
O5-9 decided it was best not
to worry about it too much.
He grabbed his office golf equipment
and began teeing up another putt.
After all, you never know when you won’t
get another chance for something like this…
Now go check out “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The
Full Story Compilation” and “SCP-001- Scarlet
King - Dust and Blood” for more anomalies that
could forever change the world as we know it!